[Musik]
die intensivstation
das bedeutet leben am limit medizin im
grenzbereich in mehr als 1300
krankenhäusern können über 26.000
menschen intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden 24 stunden am tag sieben tage die
woche
kaum ein beruf fordert von seinen
mitarbeiterinnen so viel ab wie die
arbeit auf einer intensivstation ist zur
belastungsgrenze
gerade dann wenn die patienten noch
kinder sind
sybille koletzko es oberärztin in der
haunerschen kinderklinik wie sieht er
auf der station intern 1 hier sind
schwer kranke kinder die die kleine
sophie untergebracht die zweijährige ist
eingeliefert wurden mit hohem fieber
blut abgenommen würde vorschlagen
erwarten die werte noch ab und dann
würde ich nochmal auf sie zukommen
es sind doch super nachricht ja bis vor
kurzem sophie völlig gesund gewesen doch
plötzlich quasi von einem tag auf den
anderen habe sich alles geändert so ihr
vater stefan malz blau angelaufen ganz
ganz schwach gewesen von einem kurzen
zeit und es ging einen schwarzen
mittwoch eingeliefert freitag erste
chemotherapie
seitdem seien sie immer wieder hier und
wie geht es nun weiter
als nächstes steht an wahrscheinlich
nochmal eine chemotherapie und am ende
irgendwann also sprich mitte januar es
analysiert eine
stammzellentransplantation
und dafür braucht sophie dringend einen
stammzellenspender
aber bei aller sorge die beiden haben
glück dass sie überhaupt auf der station
aufgenommen werden konnten
besprechung im team in der nacht ist ein
notfall ein kleines mädchen eingeliefert
worden
es konnte hier jedoch nicht versorgt
werden aus platzgründen ganz münchen
kein einziges bett kann intensiv bett
kein normales bei den ganz münchen
wieder die hölle
fünf stunden dauerte es bis sich endlich
eine klinik fand die das kind aufnehmen
konnte knapp 100 kilometer entfernt wir
versorgen nur noch den notstand hier und
es gibt viele tage im jahr wo kein
einziges politisches bett in münchen für
kranke kinder verfügbar ist vor der op
abteilung wartet florian zufall seine
tochter sofia leidet an einer
fehlbildung der blutgefäße vor der leber
was bereits zu lebensbedrohlichen
blutungen geführt hat es muss ständig
kontrolliert werden
wahnsinnig viel stress mehr von stress
und hoffe dass alles gut geht letzten
jahr über eine stelle die wo kurz vorm
bluten war um gott sei dank ist der
termin rechtzeitig wiesen aber nach oben
sibylle koletzko und ihr kollege
eberhard lutz führen die magenspiegelung
bei sophia selbst durch der für die
endoskopie zuständige arzt ist krank
benötigt die vierjährige einen erneuten
eingriff nur hier gibt es spezialisierte
ärzte die sie behandeln können
allerdings nicht immer katastrophe oft
drei monaten voll das auch gesagt worden
ist und dann wieder einmal auf andere
stationen weil die station intern eins
belegt überbelegt war
und immer die spannung bis zum schluss
hoffentlich aber aufgenommen nach einer
stunde warten endlich entwarnung im
verlauf ist für mich recht stabil und
gar nicht besser von der speiseröhre
herr war sehr erfreulich ist eine gute
nachricht und für kinder gut wenn der
eingriff nicht so groß ausfällt und die
mutter wieder aufgenommen werden kann
vor der kleinen folgen weil die geht es
herrscht also sehr gute nachrichten 7000
kinder werden hier pro jahr behandelt
über die hälfte haben schwere chronische
und seltene erkrankungen
der bedarf an medizinischer versorgung
ist viel höher
durch die betten stehen leer es fehlt an
personal die folgen so der leiter der
kinderklinik christoph klein seien
gravierend es passiert immer häufiger
das wirklich annehmen können oder auch
wegschicken müssen ich habe von meinen
telefonat geführt mit einer mutter deren
kind verstorben ist leider in einer
kleinen klinik in nordbayern und sie mir
eigentlich auch ihr herz ausgeschüttet
hat warum wir nicht in der lage waren
auf der intensivstation liegt ein
kleines mädchen mit einer chronischen
lebererkrankung und einer schweren
infektion
es kämpft um sein leben seit tagen für
das team ist es eine große
herausforderung zeitkräfte und
kostenintensiv der druck ist immens
doch mit kranken kindern lasse sich kein
geld verdienen so christoph klein
abrechnungen über fallpauschalen wie bei
erwachsenen auf kleine patienten seien
sie nicht übertragbar dreijährigen vor
der mrt braucht eine kernspintomographie
der legt sich nicht wieder erwachsene
und lässt sich durch getaktet
untersuchen
der wehrt sich da schreit all das stört
die abläufe
all das kostet geld und das bedeutet
ökonomisch unsinnigen strich dass die
hoch differenzierte kindermedizin sich
nicht nur uns im abschluss zeigen wie
hoch differenzierte kindermedizin sie
hat sein leben gerettet matthäus 13
monate alt kurz nach seiner geburt wurde
ein angeborener immundefekt festgestellt
vor wenigen wochen bekam er hier in der
klinik eine knochenmarkspende
wir haben jetzt glaube ich schon die
aufregendste zeit hinter uns trotzdem
hofft man natürlich immer dass die werte
gut sind dass jetzt nicht irgendwie
weltbewegendes rauskommt von anfang an
betreut schwester anja den kleinen
matteo nach den zermürbenden wochen für
mutter und kind ist auch sie froh
erfolgreich verabschieden kann dann ist
es natürlich immer da waren sich die
sache in wenigen tagen darf matteo nach
hause ich freue mich jetzt einfach dass
es so gut gelaufen ist und dass wir dann
auch heimkommen und normalität einkehrt
zur normalität gehören für sybille
koletzko und ihre kollegen der stetige
kampf um das wohl des kindes allen
widrigen umständen zum trotz
wir verwalten ja hier nicht nur kinder
und betreuen die sondern wir von festem
zins mangel und wir müssen uns ständig
entscheiden welches kind ist wichtiger
was ist das wichtigste was wir unsere
knappen ressourcen einsetzen
noch einmal macht sie die runde auf
station besucht den kleinen jetzt mehr
denn nach einer lebertransplantation
hier zur kontrolle ist mir geht's gut
stimmt das wasser das so müde bist es
seien momente wie dieser sagt sie
die sie und ihr team immer wieder zu
höchstleistungen motivieren das ist ein
sehr gutes gefühl dass alle immer das
kind im blick haben und sind auch
wirklich oft gelingt die kinder guten
weg zu bringen
nach zwölf stunden ist ihr arbeitstag zu
ende
morgen früh um acht werden sie wieder
für ihre kleinen patienten da seien mit
ganzer kraft
[Musik]
das rhein maas klinikum in würselen
hier können bis zu 30 erwachsene
patienten intensivmedizinisch betreut
werden
und es sind nicht nur corona patienten
die hier behandelt werden müssen
chef der intensivstation ist dr guido
schiek hier auf der intensivstation wird
ja dann maximale medizin betrieben
wann kommen sie da an ihre grenzen nun
wir kommen an unsere grenzen wenn wir
sehen dass die erkrankung so weit
fortgeschritten ist dass wir mit den
modernen möglichkeiten nicht mehr in der
lage sind das ruder rumzureißen
oder wir kommen eben auch an unsere
grenzen denn der patient letztendlich
nicht mehr möchte der patient steht wie
gesagt im mittelpunkt manchmal ist es
auch tatsächlich so dass man könnte aber
nicht darf oder aber dass die therapie
schon ausgereizt ist und der patient am
ende des lebens steht dann kommt es aber
dazu oder dann ist es wichtig dass wir
hier nicht eine therapie beenden sondern
wir nennen das therapieziel änderungen
dafür sorgen dass wir den patienten auf
seinem letzten weg würde voll begleiten
jetzt haben sie auch eine ganz intensive
phase mit bekommen wenn man das so
nennen kann die korona pandemie die
bis jetzt noch nicht wirklich
abgeklungen ist wie haben sie das
empfunden als dann die ersten
komapatienten hierhin kam was konnten
sie da machen
nun es war so dass wir relativ schnell
mit einer neuen erkrankung konfrontiert
wurden
wo wir kein therapeutisches tool hatten
mit dem wir diese erkrankung behandeln
konnten sondern wir konnten nur mit
guter basis intensiv medizin den
patienten über die kritische phase
bringen aber standen auch oft genug vor
der frage gibt es hier überhaupt noch
eine möglichkeit die wucht mit der uns
diese neue erkrankung auch hier in
diesem krankenhaus getroffen hat war
schon enorm und auch dass der gedanke
daran dass das was wir hier vor halten
gar nicht mehr ausreicht war eine sehr
starke belastung für uns die auf der
intensivstation
des weiteren ist sicherlich auch zu
nennen dass die mitarbeiter an einem
patienten gearbeitet haben der sie
potenziell auch infizieren konnte und
auch das ist natürlich eine belastung
und das wurde hier sehr professionell
geregelt sie haben sie angesprochen dass
die intensiv kapazitäten die sie hier
vor halten konnten während der korona
wellen ausreichend waren was wäre denn
gewesen wenn die sparmaßnahmen die die
politik ja lange schon auf dem schirm
hat sie mit intensivbetten vorher
gegriffen hätte nun gut sicherlich waren
wir kurz davor eine phase zu bekommen in
der wir nicht mehr jeden patienten so
behandeln hätten können
was dann gewesen wäre es schwierig zu
sagen sicherlich ist es so dass mehr
menschen gestorben wären
mehr menschen auf einer intensivstation
aber auch außerhalb eine intensivstation
gestorben wären
und insofern ist bisher das management
weitestgehend in ordnung gewesen
aus meiner sicht also würden sie als
intensivmediziner auch sagen dass man
lieber etwas mehr an intensiv
kapazitäten vorhält um eben auf fälle
wie eine pandemie vorbereitet zu sein
ich glaube man muss immer überlegen wer
muss auf eine intensivstation welche
menschen möchten auf eine
intensivstation welche menschen sind
vielleicht zu krank für eine
intensivstation dass es ein generelles
problem oder eine generelle frage die zu
klären ist und hier muss sich jeder
fragen wie weit soll medizin gehen und
wo sollte man andere aspekte des
lebensendes in den vordergrund setzen
ich glaube eine pandemie oder eine
katastrophe kann nur individuell
geregelt werden beziehungsweise mit
kraftanstrengung aller es ist die lunge
leber corona krankenhaus staat
angegriffen ist und das atmen kaum noch
möglich macht als letztes mittel kann
hier die sogenannte ego geraten zum
einsatz kommen der sauerstoff im blut
wird hier außerhalb des körpers
ausgetauscht der entscheidende moment
über wochen war herr chen yuan an eine
ecke angeschlossen
der letzte versuch sein leben zu retten
wir werden die ekm uhr jetzt wieder
abschalten sagt der arzt bleiben sie
ruhig versuchen sie wieder zu atmen
atmen
das konnte herr chen irgendwann nicht
mehr da lag ja schon länger auf intensiv
jede beatmungs therapie schlug fehl
so schwer war seine lunge von cobit 19
geschädigt in diesen situationen ist es
dann tatsächlich erforderlich und auch
voller perspektive wenn man eine ecke
ins
die alternative ersticken patienten mit
lungen versagen werden auf der
intensivstation in der regel beatmet die
beatmungsmaschine presst sauerstoff in
die lunge dieser gelangt über die lunge
ins blut doch bei manchen kritischen
kurs 19 patienten ist dieser weg
irgendwann blockiert die angegriffene
lunge lässt keinen sauerstoff mehr durch
die eco löst das problem sie umgeht die
lunge des patienten und versorgt dessen
blut außerhalb des körpers mit
sauerstoff durch einen implantierten
katheter saugt die eco verbrauch des
kohlendioxid reiches blut aus einer
großen bühne eine pumpe erledigt das
substanzen die heparin sind beigemischt
damit das blut nicht gerinnt
herzstück der anlage der oxigin ator die
künstliche hightech lunge hier wird das
blut von kohlendioxid befreit mit
sauerstoff beladen und fließt zurück zum
patienten
solange diese an die ethno angeschlossen
ist kann sich seine lunge wieder erholen
hat die lunge keine chance auf erholung
setzen die ärzte die eco nicht ein
auch in deutschland kämpfen ärzte mit
eck muss um das leben der patienten die
kliniken haben rund 750 geräte in
bestand gemeldet knapp 240 davon sind
aktuell im einsatz
mit gutem erfolg wie hier im münchner
klinikum rechts der isar wir haben den
luxus eco einsetzen zu können das ist
nicht überall so
und das trägt auch dazu bei dass wir
gute überlebensraten haben nicht als
einzige methode
es ist aber ein ganz essentieller
bestandteil für die ganz schwer
betroffenen patienten
genaue zahlen gibt es noch nicht aber
experten gehen davon aus dass jeder
zweite patient überlebt dennoch die
lebensretterin ist kein allheilmittel
ihr einsatz ist riskant an der uniklinik
mainz zeigt man uns einen grund die
brachialen katheter wie sie implantieren
müssen wenn man
die invasive tät also das eingreifen in
den körper das katheter platzieren und
so weiter doch vermeiden kann
beispielsweise durch eine konventionelle
überdruck beatmung mit lagerungs
therapie dann würde ich für mich für
meine angehörigen und für jeden mir
anvertrauten patienten zunächst auf die
ecken verzichtet
er schenkt der auf die app nicht
verzichten konnte hat es geschafft
bleibt bei bewusstsein als sie die
maschine abklärung augen offen und dann
die ersten eigenen atemzüge die lunge
funktioniert wieder
besser geht's nicht mit 19 überlebt
seine familie hat ihn wieder sei dank
gerade in der korona krise kommen viele
krankenhäuser an ihrem limit
es gab schlicht keine beatmungs plätze
mehr in einigen ländern musste eine
triage angewendet werden
eine auswahl welche patienten behandelt
werden können und welche stern müssen
es ist das horrorszenario für jeden arzt
oder ärztin was passiert wenn zu viele
patienten auf die intensivstation müssen
und man entscheiden muss über leben und
tod sowie in norditalien im elsass und
in einigen regionen von spanien wie
sucht man dann aus wer an ein
beatmungsgerät kommt und wer nicht
in diesen fällen schlägt die stunde der
triage ein französischer begriff der
soviel bedeutet wie auslese oder
sortierung und eigentlich nur ein
eleganteres wort ist für selektion
ihren ursprung hat die triage im krieg
als militär ärzte auf den
schlachtfeldern bestimmen mussten welche
verletzten zuerst behandelt werden
sollen
nach dem krimkrieg im neunzehnten
jahrhundert entwickelte der russische
arzt nikolaj prokop ein prinzip das die
opfer in gruppen einteilt je nach
schwere der verletzung
heute kommt die trias vor allem in
katastrophenfällen zum einsatz wie schon
beim ec unglück von eschede
die opfer werden mit farblichen karten
aufgeteilt in diejenigen die sofort
hilfe benötigen die später drankommen
können
und diejenigen die ohne klinische
versorgung auskommen zu corona zeiten
country aber auch bedeuten rot für
diejenigen die gar nicht mehr beatmet
werden sollen
doch wie geht diese selektion dann
vonstatten
eine vereinigung der intensivmediziner
hat empfehlungen veröffentlicht
entscheidend für sie sind nicht das
alter oder soziale kriterien sondern nur
die klinische erfolgsaussicht einer
therapie und die auswahl soll unter
allen kranken die eingeliefert werden
getroffen werden nicht nur unter cupid
19 patienten
ähnliche vorschläge gibt es in
österreich und in der schweiz
der ältere patient mit der kogit 19
erkrankung kann in einer in einem
besseren zustand sein eine bessere
prognose haben als eine jüngere
patienten nach einem schweren
verkehrsunfall mit vielen verletzungen
und deshalb kann durchaus auch in dem
fall dem älteren sowie patienten der
vorzug für eine intensivbehandlung
gegeben werden
entschieden werden soll aber immer nach
dem mehr augen prinzip mindestens von
zwei personen
es sind szenarien die sich kein arzt
vorstellen möchte die dr schick mussten
sie schon mal eine triage anwenden nein
mussten wir nicht zum glück wir waren
immer in der individualmedizin und
mussten nicht auf dem katastrophen modus
umschalten
dennoch war es gut dass die
fachgesellschaften schon zu einem
relativ frühen zeitpunkt in der pandemie
sich darüber gedanken gemacht haben und
auch gewisse handlungsempfehlungen für
die ärzte und pflegekräfte aber eben
hauptsächlich für die ärzte
ausgearbeitet haben an die man sich
hätte handeln können aber letztendlich
stand bisher immer der einzelne patient
im mittelpunkt unseres tuns
das ist aber eine triage ein besonderer
fall aber sie als intensivmediziner
stehen ja oft vor der entscheidung wann
kann ich noch weiter behandeln was nutzt
es den patienten und wann muss ich
einfach mit der wandlung aufhören weil
man ja alles gegeben hat sicherlich
müssen wir uns jeden tag mehrfach
gedanken machen ob das was wir tun noch
zielführend ist zielführend im sinne
einer heilung oder einer wiederkehr ins
normale leben
aber trotzdem gibt es die situation wo
wir zusammen mit dem patienten den
angehörigen und unseren kollegen
besprechen ob dieses ziel noch zu
erreichen ist
ansonsten haben wir auch noch die
möglichkeit über eine ethische
fallbesprechungen spezielle
fragestellungen zu erörtern
das ganze ist aber immer wieder eine
individuelle entscheidung die auch sehr
belastend sein kann und wird dann
manchmal auch mehr medizin gemacht als
notwendig dass man sagt okay man will
jetzt auch gerade für die angehörigen
noch mal zeigen
man hat alles getan auch wenn man
innerlich weiß da ist nicht mehr viel zu
machen schon gut letztendlich ist es so
dass wir den patienten behandeln und
nicht die angehörigen dennoch haben wir
natürlich immer weh gabelungen
man sich entscheiden muss und wir alle
entscheiden uns primär für das leben da
kann es auch mal sein dass wir im
nachhinein therapien durchführen die man
hätte schon nichts mehr durchführen
sollen
aber wie gesagt wir müssen das jeden tag
neu entscheiden und entscheiden das auch
jeden tag medizin am lebensende hier auf
den intensivstationen ein schmaler grat
zwischen leben und tod in der freiburger
uniklinik kämpft intensivmediziner
johannes kal penn täglich um das leben
seiner schwerkranken patienten und muss
für jeden die passende therapie finden
grundsätzlich ist in der sich medizin
was total tolles und das ist einfach gut
dass wird es haben und das bietet ganz
ganz vielen menschen die möglichkeit
situationen zu überleben akute
erkrankungen zu überleben
die sie vor ein paar jahren vielleicht
noch nicht so gehabt hätten und auch die
fortschritte intensiv medizin bieten
diese möglichkeit aber mit jedem
verfahren dass wir neu entwickeln mit
jedem organ das wir ersetzen können
wächst natürlich auch die verantwortung
zu entscheiden ist das denn überhaupt
sinnvoll das zu tun
die möglichkeiten der modernen medizin
stellen johannes kal penn und sein team
oft vor schwierige entscheidungen wenn
medizinische fortschritt und der
fortschritt in der organe ersatztherapie
zb in der linse halten eine therapie der
hat die ethische diskussion darum weit
überholt
man muss aufpassen in der
intensivmedizin dass die intensiv
medizin nicht zum selbstzweck wird als
wir dürfen nicht sagen wir machen
intensiv medizin weil wir es können
zusätzlich stehen ärzte auch oft vor der
herausforderung den willen ihrer
patienten ermitteln zu müssen
denn häufig können die sich nicht mehr
selbst äußern weil sie bewusstlos sind
dann ist es hilfreich wenn sich der
patient schon als gesunder mensch damit
auseinandergesetzt hat was er in solch
einem fall will und was nicht und
bestenfalls eine präzise formulierte
patientenverfügung vorliegt ich finde es
ganz ganz wichtig dass man in der
patientenverfügung formuliert was ist
mir denn eigentlich wichtig also was
definiert für mich lebensqualität
also ich möchte gerne sprechen können
zum beispiel ich möchte gerne mit
menschen interagieren können über
sprache sprache ist mir was wichtig ist
kann man ihr schreiben und das sollte
man sich auch nicht so ich sag mal
salopp überlegt sondern man sollte sich
schon überlegen was sind dann
einschränkungen die möchte ich natürlich
eigentlich nicht aber ich könnte damit
wahrscheinlich vielleicht doch irgendwie
wieder einem sinn entdecken und
vielleicht mein leben so umstrukturieren
dass ich damit auch umgehen kann
doch wenn ein patient sich nicht mehr
selbst äußern kann und keine
patientenverfügung vorliegt ist es für
mediziner oft schwer den sogenannten
mutmaßlichen patientenwillen
herauszufinden
der mann von frieda plus testament und
hat krebs
er möchte nicht gezeigt werden hat aber
nichts dagegen dass wir mit der kamera
im krankenzimmer dabei sind der muss
immer öfter ins krankenhaus und ist
mittlerweile sehr schwach weitere
aufwendige medizinische versorgung wäre
nötig aber würde die sein leiden nicht
nur verlängern
also es ist manchmal finde ich so die
herausforderung heraus zu kitzeln
was ist jetzt wunsch des patienten was
ist jetzt der wunsch der angehörigen die
natürlich immer hoffen kann mein lieber
der da jetzt liegt das patient nicht
einfach länger bei mir sein kann ich
doch alles gut werden und gleichzeitig
nicht jetzt meine wert vorstellung von
leben pflegebedürftigkeit also weiter
auf die zu übertragen sondern wirklich
herauszukitzeln was würde der konzern
freundin ob ein assist um das
herauszufinden will johannes kal penn
heute ein so genanntes angehörigen
gespräch führen solche gespräche dienen
medizinern dazu den mutmaßlichen willen
ihrer patienten herauszufinden einen
angehörigen gespräch kann über das
fortführen oder das beenden einer
therapie entscheiden familie plus
erlaubt uns das gespräch mit der kamera
zu begleiten
also wir haben tumor der weiter wächst
der wächst langsam
ja das ist zehn jahre gewachsen bis zu
dem zustand und in der zeit hat er ja
auch eine gute zeit noch gehabt und wir
können schon insoweit kriegen dass er
auch außerhalb einer intensivstation mit
sehr sehr viel pflege leben kannst
er wird aber unserer ansicht nach nicht
mehr dauerhaft zu hause sein können weil
er dann vollumfänglich pflegebedürftig
ist und er wird so wie wir das sehen
nicht mehr die zeit haben und nicht mehr
die kraft haben nochmal das selbständige
laufen so zu lernen dass man sagen kann
er ganz dann halt wie sie es gesagt
haben am rollator unterwegs so was das
wird nicht mehr passieren das ist die
dass wir als prognose sagen können aber
natürlich gibt es auch immer die
möglichkeit zu sagen wir ändern das
therapieziel das heißt wir sind nicht
mehr dann als intensivstation dafür
zuständig dass er auf teufel komm raus
überlebt sondern wir sind zuständig
dafür für ihn da zu sein und zugucken
dass er keinen durst hat dass er kein
hunger hat dass er keine schmerzen hat
und würden dann aber auch in kauf nehmen
dass er verstirbt daran und da hängt
dann immer nur noch so ein bisschen
davon ab oder vollständig davon ab was
würde denn ihr mann sagen wenn er hier
sitzen würde
ständig ist nur verlängerung von
leidensweg
das ist exakt das ist ja es macht keinen
sinn ist nicht mehr in seinem sinne
familie brust hat nach dem gespräch
zusammen mit dem ärzte-team eine
entscheidung getroffen
herr bloß soll keine weitere
intensivtherapie bekommen
[Musik]
nachdem die dreharbeiten beendet waren
ist er auf einer palliativstation
gestorben
[Musik]
sterben lassen ist ja per se jetzt
erstmal nicht immer was ganz
fürchterliches sondern manchen manchmal
das etwas erlösendes und am ende ist es
das was jedem von uns irgendwann mal
bevorsteht also das ist ja normal sich
jeder von uns wird irgendwann sterben
und deswegen ist sterben lassen ganz
grundsätzlicher anteil
der medizin grundsätzlich aber natürlich
auch der intensiv medizin wir müssen
menschen sterben lassen einfach weil wir
es gar nicht verhindern können
[Musik]
jetzt einmal viele beispiele gesehen
das leben am limit die grenze zum tod
wann ist ein mensch tot wann hört das
leben auf in einer medizinischen
definition
das ist fast schon eine philosophische
frage
letztendlich das leben entweder auf wenn
das herz aufhört zu schlagen
oder aber wenn wir aufgrund einer
erkrankung des gehirns einen sogenannten
irreversiblen funktionsausfall
nachweisen können dass ist ein ganz
besonderes thema ist die klassische
hirntod früher nannte man das so
mittlerweile nennt man das irreversiblen
funktionsausfall dieser begriff wurde in
der organen transplantationsmedizin
geprägt letztendlich ist dann auch ein
leben so wie wir uns das vorstellen
nicht mehr möglich ansonsten wenn
natürlich das herz nicht mehr schlägt
kein blut mehr durch die adern fließt
dann zwei mensch tot
wenn man jetzt aber weiter denkt
theoretisch könnte man ja ein
künstliches herz einsetzen und dann
schlägt das weiter und hält somit den
blutkreislauf am leben macht das dann
noch sinn man gut die frage der
sinnhaftigkeit ist auch wieder eine sehr
individuelle entscheidung letztendlich
muss jeder mensch für sich selber
entscheiden welches leben für sich
sinnhaft ist dies ist nicht unsere
aufgabe zu beantworten sondern das
funktioniert nur im kontext mit dem
patienten oder auch den angehörigen und
ist eine ganz ganz schwere frage
wenn man nicht auf der intensivstation
ist im schlimmsten fall auch beatmet
werden muss ist es jetzt zu spät seinen
eigenen willen zu bekunden
welchen weg können patienten den vorher
gehen um ihnen da die arbeit oder auch
die entscheidung zu erleichtern
also hier ist ganz klar die
patientenverfügung zu nennen
jeder mensch sollte eine
patientenverfügung verfassen und sie
auch regelmäßig mit einer
vertrauensperson besprechen
hier geht es nicht nur darum dass eine
notarielle oder sonstwie formalistische
dokument durch irgendwann gefertigt wird
sondern dass ganz klar der wille
ersichtlich ist und das auch in
regelmäßigen abständen
leben und arbeiten im grenzbereich
in mehr als 1300 krankenhäusern können
über 26.000 menschen intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden europaweit ein
spitzenwert
nur dank dieser vorhaltung konnten die
intensivstation in deutschland die
bisherigen corona wellen auffangen
[Musik]